I'm coyote Peterson and I'm about to
enter the pinch down with the dungeon
it's crap I wonder how much it would
hurt to get pinched by that crowd
well almost five million viewers have
watched this coyote howl in pain for
almost a minute courtesy of this
colossal crustacean nasty I gotta try to
get my finger out man crush my finger
put it down the rock what did he think
was gonna happen how is this Dungeness
crab able to deliver a pinch of pure
power the claw has strong muscles and
the power of these muscles is immense ah
see that make you produce a pinch force
of about 60 pounds or 27 kilograms
pound for pound this crabs closing claw
muscle produces some of the highest
forces ever measured for any muscle in
any animal to make matters worse the
inside of the claw is lined with ridges
so that force is actually concentrated
on a very very small part Cody's hand
the force delivered by those ridges is
equivalent to a person standing in
stiletto heels putting all of their
weight on one heel ouch
now that's impressive